all right let's get into a breaking
story that
many in the audience will appreciate and
unfortunately some in the audience will
be furious
that i'm even talking about this there
are
new kremlin papers which
appear to show vladimir putin's plot
to put donald trump in the white house
important this doesn't mean that
trump and putin met to concoct this plan
or that trump was directly involved
the whole point is what has been said
all along for people who love to say
russia gate russia gate russiagate
that russia had a preference for trump
because of the cartoonish and
destabilizing
nature that his presidency would have
and they
worked to help him regardless
of what trump knew or participated in
documents suggest russia launched secret
multi-agency effort to interfere in u.s
democracy
go by what is said not by what you
imagine i am saying and want to refute
the report vladimir putin personally
authorized a secret spy agency operation
to support a quote mentally unstable
donald trump in the 2016 u.s
presidential election
during a closed session of russia's
national security council
according to what are assessed to be
leaked kremlin documents
the key meeting took place on january
22nd 2016
with the russian president his spy
chiefs and senior ministers all present
they agreed a trump white house would
help secure moscow's strategic
objectives among them social turmoil in
the us
and a weakening of the american
president's negotiating position
how could anyone be surprised by this
put for all the people who say david you
love to criticize putin
putin's brilliant putin's brilliant
russia is brilliant at this
of course if you're russia you china and
the us
are the three major superpowers vying
for
the next decade or two of supremacy
among that that group of three what
could do more damage to the united
states
than electing a cartoonish [ __ ] like
donald trump
russia smart i'm not criticized of
course
they tried to do this and unfortunately
the republican electorate and
subsequently enough of the electorate
that voted in the general election
uh fell for it and trump won
it doesn't mean trump and putin met to
plan this
that's not how intelligence operations
work russia's three spy agencies were
ordered to find practical ways to
support trump
in a decree appearing to bear putin's
signature these are the documents
believed to now be
authenticated by this point trump was
the front-runner in the republican
party's nomination race
a report prepared by putin's expert
department recommended moscow use all
possible force to ensure a trump victory
this is also relevant because those
saying
well putin was involved even during the
primary
increasingly it looks like trump
surfaced to the top of the republican
primary
thanks just to the ignorance of the
republican electorate that votes in the
primary
at that point at which it seemed that
trump was in the commanding position
that's when russia got the idea hey
would be real imagine the laughing stock
that the u.s
would be if donald trump defeated
hillary clinton whatever your thoughts
are about hillary clinton
western intelligence agencies are
understood to have been aware of the
documents for some months
and to have carefully examined them the
papers seen by the guardian
seem to represent a serious and highly
unusual leak
from within the kremlin let me propose
something to you
okay this is this is speculation that's
what we do this is an opinion
show i want to just float an idea there
seems to be agreement
that these documents are legitimate and
there seems to be
agreement that this high-level leak from
the kremlin
is unusual okay i'm just gonna float
something here
recently joe biden and vladimir putin
met and as far as
we believe earlier even more recently
joe biden and vladimir putin spoke
believed to be related to
cyber attacks i'm just asking
is it possible is it possible that
part of the negotiation that took place
was
that on the one hand biden
would resist a counter-attack
shutting down a russian oil pipeline and
in exchange in exchange some documents
would leak from the kremlin which rarely
happens
which would illuminate exactly this
about russia's preference and work to
help donald trump
i don't know and the really funny part
about that
is that there's this idea that trumpists
have about how you project power as a
leader
that comes from trump's cartoonish
nature
you push aside the montenegrin president
or president but the prime minister
i believe president um and you talk in a
certain way and you say certain
things about kim jong-un and putin or
whatever the real way that power
actually works is you don't stomp around
and scream like a child like trump does
it's by direct uh undisclosed
calls uh uh where you you say to a
leader hey this
this is how it has to be if you want
this then you have to do that
um and it it's just an idea because it
is unusual that such documents would
leak from the kremlin so
is there anything surprising here no
there really isn't no this is
this is everything we believed uh and
that made simply logical sense
um and uh that is uh that that is what
it is now of course not surprisingly the
kremlin is responding dismissively
putin's spokesman dmitry peskov says the
idea that russian leaders met and agreed
to support trump in early 2016 is a
great pulp fiction
the report number 3204 vd
is classified as secret it says trump is
the most promising candidate from the
kremlin's point of view
um there's a brief psychological
assessment of trump who's described as
an impulsive mentally unstable and
unbalanced individual
who suffers from an inferiority complex
there is also apparent confirmation
that the kremlin possesses compromi or
potentially compromising material on
trump
collected the document says from trump's
earlier non-official visits to russian
federation territory
the paper refers to certain events that
happened during trump's trips to moscow
security council members are invited to
find details in appendix 5.
at paragraph 5 the document states it's
unclear what the appendix
contains it is acutely necessary to use
all possible force to facilitate his
election to the post
of u.s president so nothing surprising
of course there are people who are going
to say this is also part of the lie
but you know for for me this has always
been there's not going to be any smoking
gun of trump and putin meeting anybody
who's expecting that anybody who was
even expecting the russia stuff to lead
to trump's removal
as you can go back to april of 2017
where i say that's the wrong expectation
that's not how it works that's not
that's not what this is
uh but the clear motivation for russia
to make the u.s a cartoonish laughing
stock by helping trump
it's obvious it would be weird if russia
didn't do it
because it's such an obvious
intelligence opportunity
many countries would think of it but
wouldn't have the know-how or the means
to carry it out
russia's really good at getting
themselves involved in this stuff that's
the
that's the reality one of the best ways
to support our show is by supporting our
sponsors
and today one of those sponsors is
sheath underwear it's the summer
it's hot and humid meaning with
traditional underwear
we're dealing with sweating sticking and
chafing
that is what sheath underwear is solving
with the unique
boxer brief design with the multiple
ergonomic compartments in the front
keeping everything separate dry cool and
comfortable this is the future
of underwear stop wearing uncomfortable
underwear
that constricts and mashes instead keep
yourself comfy and sweat free
with sheath underwear my experience with
it has been fantastic
i'm recommending it to everybody do
yourself a favor
try an awesome product you can find a
link right underneath this video
and don't forget to use the promo code
pacman for 20
off